yoginthe tunde bates outdoors as he
prepares for a long day at this
construction site where he lives with
his family in a makeshift shack
like hundreds of millions of indians
he's forced to risk their health and
work in the record-breaking heat
let me make your head
so earlier we did masonry of 100 feet
but now we can do only 70 feet our
contractors often get angry with us
because of this i feel weak and need to
rest for a day or two it's too hot but
if we don't work what will we eat
someone parts of south asia arrived
early this year
march was the hottest in a century in
the region while april broke several
records average temperatures are six to
nine degrees celsius above normal
some areas in new delhi recently
surpassed 49 degrees chacobabad in
southeast pakistan reached an all-time
high of 51 degrees
dozens of people have died of heat
related illnesses in pakistan while
millions are struggling without basic
amenities such as access to clean water
and
we electricity seen such a heat wave
before we're worried because our
livestock's sick due to the excessive
heat the vegetation's dried up the water
table's going down we have to use wet
clothes to cover ourselves to try to
beat the heat the extreme heat is
damaging crops and threatening to
further increase food prices making the
poor even more vulnerable i mean so much
of your population is hit in such a big
way that government does not have the
fiscal capacity as simple as that in
these countries you know
so so that is the biggest
another very big point of vulnerability
for this region along with the climate
factors it's also the economic kind of
situation of these regions
scorching temperatures have spurred
demand for electricity causing a cold
shortage the indian government says
it'll import coal to prevent power cuts
and it's not just the blistering heat
experts say global warming is changing
weather patterns in the region while
rainfall in northern india has been much
lower than normal the northeast is
reeling from heavy rains at least 10
people have been killed and landslides
have cut off basic services for
thousands of people bhavni mittal
al-jazeera new delhi